here what do you guys want to hear a rap
about richard iii
[ __ ] out okay you
are you from you from leicester no
in fact they found him in a leicester
car park right that was that's what
happened in it yeah
okay cool richard the third that's a
good suggestion um
guys on on this side of the room what do
you want to hear wrap up
being 50. cool thank you very much are
you is that a
birthday you're celebrating this year
yeah good on you well done
that's a impressive impressive age to
reach
yeah i don't [ __ ] know i mean like
100 years ago yeah that's
great well done richard richard iii
wasn't 50 right you beat him
[ __ ] him he was the king as well he had
all the health care he could have wanted
no you nailed it
elvis died at 42 you're better than
elvis there you go
jim morrison joni mitchell kurt cobain
all 27
jimmy you're better than them right
being 50
richard iii what was that shot from the
back countdown
countdown that's a good suggestion
cool i like that thank you very much
someone doing the tune over there as
well yeah countdown being 50 richard the
third i want two more suggestions let's
make these good
life it's very general isn't it um
octopus that's an animal unfortunately
and a food is there
whoever said life is is there an aspect
of life that
that you're interested in menopause
okay okay the menopause
as an aspect of life richard iii
okay thank you very much for fanning a
woman that's uh
nice in it so richard the third
being 50 menopause is an aspect of life
what gabba as as in the like the hard
house happy trance
genre of music yeah okay wow that will
hit home for about seven people in here
who are probably
too [ __ ] zonked out
so gabba the menopause richard the third
being 50. now i think we've got them all
because what was the other one what was
it
countdown cool um thank you very much
that was a perfect this then lovely
people of the uh the creator comedy club
little christmas gift for you a little
thing called a freestyle rap that has a
wrap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions one
more time richard the third
being 50 the menopause countdown and
gabba
it's going to be entirely made up it
will never be seen again and do not
worry it'll not be anywhere near as
atrociously embarrassingly toe currently
bad
as you are expecting a privately
educated middle class white boy to be
you seem real behind this that's okay
let's drop that beat good sir let's show
them how we do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
shakespeare wrote a play about me not
richard one richard two but
three a horrible [ __ ] he had a hump
in his back
kevin spacey had a [ __ ] crack in the
role at the national
down in the south when he wasn't putting
16 year old boys in his mouth
that's a true fact i wanna go and say
best played by lawrence olivier
it's my favorite one of the histories
where was he buried it was a mystery
until four years ago and for a mad luck
they thought we should excavate a car
park
then down deep through the tarmac
observed that's the shopping trolley
that's richard the third they got his
body out and turned him in the chapel
moving on yeah i never had a hassle when
i'm sitting down in my front shore
i love watching all the shows on the
channel for
carol vorderman she was the one i had a
crush
on if i'm there she's asking me the
question
i say carol you thought i have forgotten
yeah
let me say one from the top and one the
bottom today
two big five small that is what i asked
for
i wanna enter carol right from the back
door
even now she's looking so nifty what's
her age
probably 50. she's still got the big
breasts though
i say let me spell it out carol foyo
i go down connor lingers on vordemon for
so long i'll be spelling all the letters
on the [ __ ] with a tongue
i'm ever so sorry it's meant to be i
have
intercourse with the half century being
50.
what an age to be means you probably
start
with the hrt a round of applause for the
menopause
lots of people get angry and of course
you're like oh we rarely discuss it
it's really hard when i get the hot
flushes
heart flashes my skin goes red it's so
exciting when you lay in bed
your husband comes home yeah he's the
dab there
he's been out dancing together why would
he do that he's from the 80s
a genre now the teams would hate these
they prefer
pop rap and all the other [ __ ] but gabba
was amazing when the baseline hit
it would go about three times the bpm
about
200 to 110 had an
mc toasting over the top and when the dj
puts the record on i hope it never stops
more rumble the jungle i say heck yo
it's better than disco or [ __ ] techno
admittedly i made up
all of that i've got good taste i don't
listen to those tracks there you go
[Music]
thank you very much for watching please
watch more with playlists here subscribe
hear like comment all those things
shouting bye